in Casey South Carolina investigators
continue to gather evidence in the death
of a six-year-old girl the medical
examiner is set to perform autopsies
today to determine the cause of death of
first grader Faye sweat llyich this is a
GoFundMe site has been created to help
the family pay for her funeral Janet
shamlian reports people stopped to leave
flowers in face sweat 'lets neighborhood
as authorities identified a neighbor
linked to her death he was not a
relative he was not a friend he was
merely a neighbor face body was found
Thursday in a wooded area near her home
just moments after locating faith Marie
sweat Lake we located a deceased male
that was Cody Scott Taylor who lived a
few hundred yards from phaz home where
she was last seen playing outside on
Monday police previously interviewed
Taylor he had no criminal record
authorities stopped short of identifying
him as the killer detectives say the
break in the case came as investigators
followed a garbage truck around the
neighborhood are you able to detail the
piece of evidence that you found by
going behind the trash truck what I will
confirm is this it was a critical piece
of evidence that would have been listed
on her missing persons flower that fire
details the clothing Faye was wearing
when last seen for CBS this morning
Saturday Janet shamlian Casey South
Carolina
you